hey everyone here welcome back to yet
another episode of watching the Watchmen
today we are on issue 8 of Doomsday
Clock Doomsday Clock is this hackneyed
cash in unnecessary bloated sequel to
Watchmen not cannon in my eyes Jeff
Jones and Gary Franks who or Gary Frank
it's just John's and Frank who have
really grown to appreciate he's a
fantastic artist I mean Jeff John's less
so in the creative Department but yet
today we are back again we are going to
be reviewing issue 8 as I say which is
called a save humanity and I'm with deaf
as always deaf how's it going
yeah good man you sound like a real fan
the way that you going on about this
book I'm quite excited to review it with
you Tom I'm sure we're gonna say lots of
positive things about this yeah issue
that we'll love doing I look for this
every week you know so you know the
cover as we always speak about we have
Bubastis on the front
I guess the eyes the the blue cat's eyes
you know kind of hinting towards
Manhattan or something in that round
he's always a yellow as well dominance
of more Watchmen colors what would you
think of the cover
lovely color Tom there's also a hints of
Rorschach's mask in the fur coloration
oh that's right I see that that's cool
yeah yeah it's a really nice touch it's
a lovely use of purple and Frank it once
again Stan you know that Tom you know
that oh man I mean the bright light on
Bubastis brow is heavenly and you can
see like flecks of the fur against the
pitch blackness and and yeah I mean
again the his paws as well I really
heavy and light yeah it's really really
nice and I don't know if you spotted it
well the the alternative cover with
Ozymandias as a sort of puppet master
yeah I did yeah I actually really like
this cover and so basically Superman's
fighting well he's not fighting him but
he's having a the stern word with dr.
Manhattan if you look doctor one hand
the point that I'm going are you and I
was human dies he's pulling the strings
on these two puppets obviously it's an
easter egg for the doctor
man online and we're all puppets I can
just see the strings which it hints
towards as human dye is manipulating
them into a faceoff which is kind of the
direction that I think this issue goes
but I don't know for definite yeah yeah
and I mean you know Manhattan John is a
character that we see really in the Ozzy
archetype not in controlling everything
but someone who's aware of anything any
forces above him so it is quite cool -
yeah it is a nice bit of artwork as well
I guess also harking back to was it was
it my marionette one of their pet was
its marionette right her parent her dad
was like a puppet maker or some [ __ ]
yeah that's right yeah yeah and
obviously it's kind of calling back to
Mars as well I'm actually drinking I
didn't even realize this is a spooky bit
of serendipity I'm actually got my dr.
Manhattan mug or my coffee where he's
holding the photo staring out into the
abyss and clearly it's harking back to
that as well I'm sort of scouring for
further things it doesn't really I mean
arguably the sort of planet that's gas
obscured in the background looks a bit
similar to what they travel over to get
to Olympus Mons but you know that is a
that is a bit of a stretch no it's
called um it's called to save humanity
we I've got to say the HL Mencken quote
that it's drawn from I've never heard
that quote before I'll just get to that
quote now I think it's a really cool
quote actually and I think it's a bit
garish that it's just called save
humanity and again it's a bit on the
nose but I do like the quote the urge to
save humanity is almost always a false
front for the urge to rule right okay
that's deep yeah I didn't even read that
quote you know I was just so excited to
finish the book
I'm so really just skip past all that
and finished off my notes and thought
alright I'm done I'm off so you were you
a bit like Bubastis in the opening
panels yawning yeah exactly just I'm
sick of it Tom I really am it's just
this entire issue it just feels like
they they've sort of forgotten all the
stuff from the last couple of issues no
Watchmen in this at all yeah they just
want to start again basically it's so
annoying it's really
really perplexing and yes we open with
Bubastis yawning we realized engines on
the carpet of the Oval Office it's quite
nice actually that she's sort of lying
in the center of the Insignia and and
the wings are outspread behind and it's
not really clear what's going on but
aziz aziz found a file an important
document well where's the president at
this point someone check Twitter and
find out where he is yeah yeah it's it's
very again it's kind of cool to see
these different toys in these different
worlds but I I'm more like just the
Bubastis image if anything than Ozzy
being there and you know this something
again it's kind of hard to see how many
you can't see at all how many stars are
on that flag but obviously we live in a
slightly demented world and we've
pointed this out at nauseam on the show
the more is one of the most you know
subtle writers in terms of the the
juxtapositions Jeff doesn't Jeff doesn't
have that so we have it's a crime Clark
Louis at the Daily Planet with Clark
here and it would have been enough for
me to just have a crime taking place
wordlessly and for us to go into it next
but the fact that it's a basic one like
a kid stealing a fruit and the fact that
the fruit seller catches him it says how
you gotta pay for it it's like we don't
need this yeah completely pointless
doesn't really tell the story and it's
not two characters kind of being polar
opposites of each other it's just there
for the sake of it and he runs again
he's just doing a poor imitation Bo
don't don't want to slug it off fully
we'll finally got Superman back Tom yeah
after eight issues he's finally back it
was it the first one where he something
wasn't yeah I think was the end of the
first one that he woke up and he's
finally back and tell you I it's it's
been a good it's worth it Tom away in
these this year and a half for his
return really worth away yeah he's got
some jokes to crack here and we're a
issues in and they're still setting up
Kirk
having what feels like it should be the
opening like lois lane's really sassy
but at this point I'm just more annoyed
than I am engrossed because of how
little plot development has been
especially like it just get to the point
John's who have got four issues left
after this you know I mean she's gone
with it please wrap it up wrap it up it
is it is infuriating and again I guess
we've got the echo of Ossie desk finding
something and Louis finding something at
her desk and there's just lots of stuff
in this sequence like the kool-aid stuff
I don't really know what they're getting
out I guess drunk the kool-aid kind of
brainwashing I guess but I don't really
like any of that stuff and yeah it's not
highbrow enough is it Tom like drinking
the kool-aid a very famous saying that
many people will get we're as shocked
when we're as Alan Moore he would have
referenced something from Victorian
poetry again like he's a hack Jones he's
a bloody Huck I mean you know think
about I think we point out when we did
when we did Watchmen and we thought if
either of us has realized it was very
very cool we're in Karnak when Ozzy
opens the dome and all the snow comes in
and covers that guy's face and then it
goes into the black freighter
you know the reflection and just so much
stuff is so seamless this sort of stuff
is an you know they caught a dilly-dally
back and forth we get the what's his
name is Jay jonah Jameson clone very
wise Perry White yeah which it may be he
came before jonah jokes in the car you
know the yet the editor thing and it
does feel like a clean slate in some
places because we do get I mean we get a
lot of it for out the series of course
we do get a lot of exposition you know
the the metahumans the Superman theory
I've kind of made it clear that I don't
really like big event comics I find them
quite quite sluggish here and but I've
got to say I've got to be positive in
some ways I do quite like the reference
to the to the diary to debase it to the
end of Watchmen at the bottom of the
page yeah you know it is quite a nice
little thing but what does it do with it
Tom
nothing really no it's just in there for
the sake of it and then we cut to
firestorm on TV
[ __ ] my storm they know where has this
really come from to be honest this this
isn't something that's been building up
at no point have they really focused on
firestorm - it he's gonna be this big
thing that's gonna eventually erupt I
think they have mentioned him he has it
has been in 180 issues for about three
panels but no point did they make this a
focus and it's just a bit ridiculous
like firestorm lands in Mexico and turns
everyone to glass because basically
firestorm the flower - you're right yeah
in Russia yeah I said Mex men must go
tom I've actually got in Mexico and my
notes as well go Mexico on the right
basically fire Psalms power is that you
can manipulate molecules and their other
elements so he does this in terms
everyone in the class it's very very
very similar to civil war right here by
Marvel which in that a bomb goes off the
superheroes get blamed for it then they
have to register their names yeah with
the government some people do some
people don't they see it as a breach of
freedom and that course is this civil
war in which the people who registered
the names have to track down the people
who haven't registered their names very
simple story Tom very well executed
brilliant brilliant book in this it
seems like they've gone for a similar
aesthetic with the meta-gene baby
testing thing in Russia making people
superheroes that sort of thing
but it's just nowhere near as good in
that this was like principle vs.
principle and that was the story where
is this we've had eight issues already
though not really discuss that plot
point and now it's suddenly getting
thrust into the eighth issue as a sort
of here's an introductory plot point
that we're going to discuss throughout
this graphic novel so no this is the end
now wrap it up - yeah just wrap it up
yeah Tom tell them wrap it up I mean in
issue eight gone all the carefully
strong Fred's should be coming together
in compelling
and yet we shouldn't like you say we
have met firestorm a few times I'm
pretty sure he's in a lot of the back
it's yeah the back panel stuff as well
the meted metahuman meta-gene stuff
again I agree is very garbled I think
civil war succeeds because it was a
really original idea and it was just
compelling and it's splitting across
lines very well whereas this one the
problem also is because it's not a civil
war because it's an international war
with Russia involved it's kind of got
this zeitgeist II here's what's actually
happening in the world in 2018 baked
into it which doesn't help I think it I
think it much I think John's is trying
to be cute here and not doing very well
and also let's say if more had to take
this story and adapt it like you did
Swamp Thing I think create a more
[ __ ] interesting character than just
human torch guy like you know I mean I
like the fact that he has two
personalities fused together in the
incident I think that's actually quite
cool that's actually quite a reach out
for fire storms like a classic DC
current you see an old character he's an
old carriage yeah he's people quite work
around for quite a while yet he looks at
yeah but he's not exactly the kind of
person that you want at the center of
your story to be honest um to me it
should be one of the big guns obviously
they do kind of thrust Superman into
that position when he disagrees we're
glad Amir Putin to his face yeah but
yeah firestorms just a bit not 1917 yard
he's from firestorm so he's not I
thought it'd be like the from the 50s or
some [ __ ]
apparent he's in the arrowverse I mean I
don't watch that myself yeah yes yeah
he's in legends of tomorrow
he's quite a big character and that it's
good but he he's dead a sort of
reimagined him in that program whereas
this is more classic firestorm and he's
not as interesting Tom Neil turns people
a glass but you know who gives a [ __ ]
yeah why is this got to do with the
Watchmen Tom and doom say climbing
pieces yeah yeah it's got no this is
kind of a you know the camel the Pro
Tour broke the camel's about the need of
sort of Archduke Franz Ferdinand kind of
idea here
so yeah this for
it's going on with him and pods are I
think he's cold
and then there's reference to because if
you remember I think one of the things
we did praise in the book was at the end
of worldly issues a fingers like issue
five or six they had a list of all the
different superior groups around the
world yeah and they all sort of
reflected their stereotype their
national stereotype and that was quite
cool so we get to see some of these guys
here that again we just get their name
so it's very hard to know they are
what's the deal with like black demon
lady and like can just through just like
going soy people in like this rate
though it's kind of cool but it doesn't
really explain I've got an idea how
shooters Tom know I genuinely don't and
and I know most DC characters yeah and I
don't think I've ever seen it before no
so lads if you want to educate me on
comics make sure you comment on this
video
and you know we have the you know the
breaking point really where our story
kind of spirals off where yeah he
explodes and turns everyone to glass and
I've got the feeling that John's fought
that this panel on see on page seven
would be this like a chronic thing or
whatever but I don't know I think the
class looks kind of cheap here I don't
think it looks very translucent it looks
kind of oily yeah to be fair it's
probably hard to color glass yeah yeah
it is maybe you should have turned them
to like gold or something
basically Firestone can turn anything
into any element and he wants you so
they could have done anything do you
think there's any sim symbolism this
glass dome like the people are so
transparent in their views that yeah I
don't think it's that time no no no I
guess yeah the inherent fragility as
well of life and and stuff like that but
no I mean this happens confusingly the
people aren't sort of gathered up by the
other superheroes and put somewhere safe
because obviously it would shatter they
left now overnight yeah they don't even
put like build anything around them like
like a fence around them so I put a wall
around them to stop people breaking in
and smashing them up just stupid Tom
really stupid
and from Pierre Superman goes to Khandaq
which is a refuge for superheroes now
again if this was an issue one or two
fair enough
but it's just bugging the pace and down
when we feel like we should be ramping
up to a climax it shouldn't be
introducing new locations this far into
the book like carnac it just seems weird
to me so it's like a utopia for
superheroes but why do they need a
utopia when most of them are invincible
wouldn't he hide out Superman also will
discover he's any sort of Dark Knight
Returns mode here where all of the other
superheroes are banned except for him
because he's a government Lackey and in
that story he was used to really ramp up
just how needed Batman was but here it's
just a bit random like honestly I just
think there's too many characters in
this book and too many storylines now
and you that you have issues that have
to focus on groups of characters but
then they get completely forgotten about
in the next issue because you've got a
focus on another group of characters and
another group and it's just characters
taken precedent over other characters to
the point that no one really has any
interesting plot elements or things to
do
and if you look at the original Watchmen
graphic novel there's about five
characters in total in that book that
other main focus here there's Ozymandias
there's the mime and Marian air Superman
and Reggie comedian Mothman Jonathan
Lois lengthy fires or black Adam what's
going on to keep focus and whilst every
issue centers around one character it
means overall as a book there's not much
cohesiveness like Superman he's being
gone for seven issues and now he's back
and we're supposed to be able to like
latch onto him as part of this story
when you're introducing a and you like
basically Superman if it wasn't Superman
and we didn't know anything about
going into this it would seem like it
introduced the character in the first
chapter and then you reintroduce them in
the eighth one and just completely scrap
it and all of the characters that he
introduced before that he's a joker no
it's got his name tomm he's that he's a
hero
basically he a Batman journalist turned
superhero but he's like a crazy one Tom
it's doing me head in Jack's I mean Jack
Ryder I think is his name and Batman I'm
quickly good ok yes not good yeah it is
Jack Ryder
he's the creeper bang I got it Tom I got
it in the end okay I mean he's offering
the child an Apple weird how I know is
like alter-ego but not is I was gonna
say is this liquor or something but this
Lincoln I just invented a new comic book
character there you'll probably see him
pop up in doomsday 12 sorry I keep an
eye out for the slicker and Supes meets
the black Adam and you know this utopia
as you say is introduced we meet a sand
guy who's actually a child and you know
again it's just not it's just not the
most inventive [ __ ] I've ever seen it's
not kind of yeah this is really carte
blank really just throw some soup herbs
into this place show us where they exist
in paradise you know we learn about all
the refugees that have sought ideas here
firestorm is this fawn in Black Adam
side now you know everyone wants to know
who these guys and it's kind of like
come on Black Adam you can probably find
him if you just fly around the world a
bit like you know I mean Superman finds
him very easily might be was on the TV a
couple of minutes ago yeah yeah yeah
live it couldn't be that you know we
said before as well I super not I like
is all-star Superman you know the kind
of wide-eyed naive but been to a million
planets sort of character and I don't
know this one the whole careful Adam I
didn't get my world
cow in today it just Falls a little flat
yeah doesn't work does it
this feels like a [ __ ] looking for a
five yes yeah we establish the
differences between these guys and again
it is drawn across these civil war lines
but in no way as captivating ah you know
of course Gary Frank is doing great
stuff as well in the sand looks looks
wonderful we you know we'll always
always praise this guy and then Lois
it's just it's so annoying to me how
boringly
information is imparted to these
characters who rules watching a TV
screen or in this case it's like you
know dawn of justice when he has the
[ __ ] pics on the little you know time
player things and you know I can help
she has this little you USB and then she
goes back and watch it a bit about
justice America sits and watches all of
the YouTube videos and she doesn't even
subscribe at the end Tom no I mean
that's what's most annoying thing that
more would always say about watch from
why couldn't be filmed cuz they did so
much in there that just wouldn't work
about this however someone literally
watching video that's what they've drawn
here it's like come on guys
really bad and you know what's even
worse about this whole utopia thing Tom
I read Avengers vs. x-men the other week
I'd heard good things about it I've
heard bad things about it
it was it was really good and in that
the x-men they build their own utopia
away from the rest of the world and then
the Avengers basically a big thing
happens and the Avengers get pissed off
about it and it's great there's a
brilliant use of the utopia and that
this one just completely pales in
comparison to it and I was just ho so
annoyed by it definitely read Avengers
vs. x-men guys if you haven't if you
like me in the air it wasn't that good
it's really really good you need to read
everything but it's really good Superman
finds firestorm very quickly which kind
of undermines the whole interaction with
black at all you better find this guy
though oh there is one
we come across him he is you know how
good would that have been if he couldn't
find him in black Adam was there was
like more and more like attacks from
firestorm happening yeah Superman was
getting the blame for them and then
black Adam how to fight him and that
would have been so much better but it's
not [ __ ] he's stolen the child as well
like yeah but I would have been easy to
would have been easy pickings as we say
they're not you know they weren't
courted off in any way he is wracked
with guilt understandably these dual
personalities are warring inside him
he's trying to work out what to do
that's quite a nice shot actually I say
shot panel on page 15 in the middle of
Superman and his face is sort of half
yeah I like that I think I think again
from friends off to the side yeah yeah
yeah it's really really cool we get a
bit of insight into his powers as well
and him changing it back and it's just
again this isn't what we [ __ ] wanted
like you know yeah one what is this I
don't know but well basically if people
didn't know read this and got a bit
confused
hey firestorms two people fused together
as one but you wouldn't have any idea of
that if this was your first comic book
it's just not accessible for those who
aren't fully up to speed and those who
are up to speed they probably don't care
be honest because you've seen this a
million times
yeah I don't know the language God
please please let this work
it's just I don't know I don't like this
at all
he impales the boy with fire I guess we
can sort of see what is it like an
isotope an atom sort of coming through
his frame in the middle of page 16 the
boy returns you know well so he's back
and what is Superman know this kid's
name it's just know every kid's name or
I don't really don't know maybe he
looked at Lisa Wallace say you had any
money decreases privat like lawyers he
knows it and any hug ximenos his phone
again that's not really explained and
again there's no forfor here from
Superman like of course if you come back
with the guy that turned them all into
class they're gonna be hostile like
maybe go in fear then explain and
okay no no trust me he's he's the kid
and the kitten the pet kid goes to his
parents okay they've got one back we got
more it's just a real fall fort here
yeah this is absolutely ridiculous like
I really don't know why they had to do
this in the middle of a press conference
with Vladimir Putin and you know just
why not wait till it's nightfall just
sneak in and turn the people back to
normal like why do it at this point yeah
it's just it's ridiculous it's like when
Batman dropped rorschach off in Arkham
even though he knew who he was and he
just saw you know I'll do it now you
wait still followed me a Putin's in
front of loads of TV cameras and drops
down and looks hostile obviously they're
gonna be hostile
yes ridiculous yeah I mean this is
ground this is ground [ __ ] zero the
bigger things I've happened in the world
so it doesn't again yeah it's the
equivalent of bin Laden showing up to
Ground Zero to like prove that he's
innocent and it was George Bush who did
it yeah
during a press conference with George
Bush yeah at Ground Zero I hate that
Vladimir Putin's in this I really do
yeah terrible isn't it like could
Watchmen did do that though to be fair
what did everybody know what I thought
it was handled really well and yeah yeah
and as soon as he popped up here or just
like oh no I thought I was like a fellow
late of comedy piece yeah Watchmen had
the president as Nixon during Reagan's
presidency but this one there's not you
know I mean there's no twist it's just
the real world exists as it does and
that's not very exciting
ya know when like a parka coat no just
looks like he's in the shop yeah and
it's kind of it's kind of hard to
imagine his ruski accent
sort of going through here with it but
again we get to see the heroes behind
him as well this little press conference
the Kremlin and you know again the arts
noise Superman arise but why is he
having a press conference in front of
the Kremlin yeah I don't know this is
the only location in Russia that Jon
Snow is about yeah yeah I mean you'd
think they had some sort of head cause
or something like that or even you
some sort of diplomatic building that
they have but yeah he declares that
they're at war and as if on cue Superman
arrives and you know tries to sort of
bargain you know what he did was an
accident you know I'm here if he trusts
me and we get to see the people in the
guys again don't know why they didn't
get partitioned off at least a little
bit I I don't get that and I mean bats
is in it though at the end we get the
bat wing above yeah so just to go back
do you feel like with Vladimir Putin
John's is sort of scared to take the
mick out of them like you has a although
your tone is understandable pisar
remember Superman speaks not for America
but for all people on this planet it's
like yeah you clearly scared who'd say
that this guy's a bad guy yeah it's like
a psychopathic murderer like hopefully
the irrational world leader I know you
mean yeah yeah it is very sick of fant
occasionally yeah and I mean he had sort
of again he didn't really even attack
Trump did he sort of he put Robert
Redford in in the presidency and
mentioned that he was golfing a bit but
you know they're kind of had a nice
platform here for him to do something
with it but that doesn't happen the
Batman's above and Batman just tell him
just just this event because you know
eventually reveals that it's not here in
blah blah blah it's a bomb or something
like that and a weird thing I don't know
why this is um notice at the bottom of
page 20 Louis has a Liverpool FC Cup oh
yeah she does yeah I did she only scouts
heritage sure nope no I think I didn't
think so over so yeah very again just a
little nods to the football team from
John's there and not really sure why
again Superman in terms of rhetoric is
maybe not the most convincing though he
is a kind of you know Vanguard and
people will listen to him but it's just
I don't know no your entrance like I
know that it's not him so it kind of
makes sense that maybe he wasn't
thinking on that straight but it's just
yeah just sort of lets me down really
and it you know when you're reading
something you really want to be kept up
in it and page
not aware where you were but for me I
was looking at the side of the screen
and how far the bar was down and I'm not
too far yeah it's really and like Batman
is well like what's happened with Batman
I can't really remember where he last
was because after Manhattan meeting was
neat yeah he was and now he's just back
on his feet flying a boat that's right
no mention of it no and he was like
issue a we're starting again because
it's like because there were so many
cool ideas here like alternative
Rorschach breaking into the Batcave and
stuff like that but they're just there
and like we said before the whole Arkham
idea of him being a being locked up as
well doesn't make any sense so I kind of
I gotta say it did sort of wince when
the bullets went through the glass I
think that's kind of effective but it is
just stupid as we said like they
shouldn't be there but but yeah that
goes down these super characters that we
don't really know attack Superman and
they're privets there as well I don't
know why Superman didn't prove it what
did see if I just keep privat to his my
I guess he's protecting him from his mom
or or something like that and and and
then yeah just just as Ozzy orchestrated
as he wanted it kinda hell breaks loose
yeah and I don't know how you would have
planned this this much no I really don't
know like it's doesn't make any sense to
be honest you so he's manipulated
Superman in the starting a war with
Russia but how how has he done yeah it's
like but do is read in that newspaper
out the stuff and files at the start but
I don't get it Tommy what did they tell
him anything just seems like a
coincidence
he seems like a massive coincidence he's
you know he's not like darts in my hand
he doesn't have this omniscience where
he knows what's going on at all times
how could he have known that Superman
would have met firestorm if that was
even first or maybe that was the stooge
himself I don't know but it's not even
if you give me a tangible reason it's
all happens but don't really care it's
just not very satisfying in of itself
it's not a very compelling plot everyone
of course is watching this from all over
the world
Louis is confused she later drops the
LFC mug but I don't so it is firestorm
but it isn't firestorm because it
clearly is him because he's upset about
the things but then Batman saying is not
it's not Firestar so he shouts isn't it
it's not firestorm
why didn't you say that at the start
exactly exactly
why is he left it till all hell's
produce when he could have just been
like flying about before and go yo
Superman it's you boy
just just one let you know it's not
firestorm it's uh you need to take them
and get out of there before all hell
breaks loose but instead he tells them
to shut up and then then tells them it's
not firestorm right at the end and then
a bomb goes off yeah I mean maybe it's a
defend John's which I'm you know not
really want to do maybe Batman didn't
know maybe it was the energy readings
spiking that alerted him to it not being
firestorm maybe and again firestorm you
know has like a few people inside his
brain or two people so maybe cause he
put someone else in there but yeah it's
a giant blue explosion you know we don't
know exactly what sort of emulation it
caused is it is it squid level it's not
clear although the fact that all the
satellites I mean again there's a really
say too much to be on TV the mug gets
dropped as well and lame writing from
Giants the villain just looking and
saying it begins yeah which annoyed me
because we're going in the issue nine
next yeah and it shouldn't be beginning
it should be ending Tom yeah yep
not that it begins please please no more
John's
please not another year of this which I
think it it's gonna be about Javier
isn't it pretty much yeah I mean eight
months I it's crazy how more managed to
write Watchmen to the deadline whereas
this is just still good Tom and all said
it a lot and I know it sounds like we're
constantly going over the same points
over and over again but it's not very
good it's not it's not very good at all
just feel so it should be an issue one
an issue a yeah I think I think a bit of
retooling this could be quite a good
issue one yeah definitely you know I
think I think it sets up a lot of cool
plot lines but yeah as you say with
seventy five eighty percent into the
whole thing doesn't make any sense
we get some back panel stuff here so I
mean so clearly the world was just
newspaper headlines really it's quite
lazy yeah I mean clearly the world
wasn't destroyed then or there wasn't
too much impact because you know there's
lots of stuff going on here about
Superman you know being missing at this
point and blah blah blah and it's all
very by the way storytelling and it you
know it's it's all very on the nose in
my eyes but I mean still deaf people out
there they really enjoy Doomsday Clock
and I love in their taught actually
haven't read it many reviews for this
one should we get some yeah I've just
I've actually got comic book roundup off
at the Marvel so the average critic
rating is eight point seven okay so
there are there is just Jones must have
loads of fake accounts there are seven
ten out of ten reviews
well that good yeah ten out of ten is it
Kevin Murphy saying might just be some
of John and John's and Frank's greatest
work yet the issue delivers a really
interesting story in conflict and draws
you in as they're as ready and makes you
want to keep reading it ends on a huge
cliffhanger that I'm ecstatic to see the
outcome off static come on man
Cameron Tevis saying that being said
it's excellent series the introductions
are done with I can only imagine how
intense the next four issues are going
to be I can't Tom yeah they're gonna be
not very tense yeah you're gonna be
about as tenses waiting at the bus stop
that the lowest reviews still quite high
six point five from Jay yours on Batman
news this is a more muted affair there
are some great scenes at the Daily
Planet no there aren't and John just
gets Superman stalwart optimism no he
doesn't something just doesn't quite
connect though making the product as a
whole a bit let down don't take it to
mean at this issue with Doomsday Clock
is bad though yes it is there's good
writing no there isn't
beautiful artwork yeah there is and a
sense of hope even in the Maya
I mean homeboy you know so it's pew in
dead I really don't know um probably not
I don't I can't see John that's making
that kind of statement no you've got to
be protected by one of the like demon
lady or something but I mean yeah as
always guys let us know down below we
seem to be GM Tom they write I'll read
you their review and then you guessed
their score alright
so doom steak this is just the the
summary paragraph Doomsday Clock eight
is an engrossing read and one that
finally gives Superman along over to you
spotlight he's just one of several DC
favorites who shines in this new chapter
unfortunately not all as well as the
series begins building towards its
climax Superman story feels too
disconnected from the rest of the books
main cast and the general pace of the
story is beginning to feel sluggish at
times when it should be heating up now
off that what would you say their score
is Tom quite negative wasn't it when you
think they've yeah I get a six issues it
or seven point five seven point five
yeah which is like their that's like the
most middle-of-the-road score you can
give that that is when our review comic
books that's the score when I'm like
alright it's not bad but yeah yeah yeah
yeah but I do agree with that statement
there it just feels completely
disconnected I don't really know what's
going on
and I don't really care oh no no um
gratz chums another classic yeah I
completely apathetic towards this I mean
for a century of completion let's finish
this and I think I said you I said you
before like you know when they are
noticed on a series is selling really
well and I think that you know in the
future when they do a hardback edition
and just market in Waterstones as the
doomsday sequel blah blah blah you're
probably quite popular you know I
definitely buy it yeah probably it might
be it might be better in one read it's
just the fact that it's two to three
months every issue and nothing's really
happening and we've got four issues left
and I don't know where it can go for
this it's got a goal from this to
Superman fighting dr. Manhattan on Mars
in four issues and so I took them seven
issues to meet dr. Manhattan the first
time yeah yeah and there there seems
need to be perfectly written and I know
they're not and I know also that this
isn't taking place in a bubble over this
has ramifications on the bigger rebirth
universe as well so you know who knows
which has been a disaster tom is that
right completely honest well you
probably know it's the the last year the
last 28 years of my life I was a very
hardcore DC fan Tom in the last year or
so I've pretty much switched to Marvel
on all fronts movies TV comic books Tom
pissed rebirth has not been good I mean
you know let us know down below in the
comments what you thought of our review
our dissenting review I think one of the
only negative voices out there about
Doomsday Clock we're the only ones who
are right Tom it's them who are wrong it
is a pile of [ __ ] it is it isn't it
isn't very good at all but you know and
get in touch for us is why watching and
watch one part at gmail.com we do read
out any emails that we receive they are
very warmly received and I think we're
saying that next time we do this death
issue 9 we're gonna try and do it live
right we'll try we'll see what happens
but we'll try yeah we've also dropped
our watchman movie review and analysis
and the channel um just drop today it's
on ninety-one views already ok so it's
not too bad
um so make sure you go listen to that
walnuts we're a lot more positive about
that I think and it's a lot more of a
fun episode than this one and you know
if you like all things Watchmen you've
come to the right place
if you also like things movie trailers
you've come to the right place as well
because they're stupidly in the last 12
hours I've done four movie trailer
breakdowns and I did Hellboy 1
and then I did another Hellboy one and I
thought our stoles was meant to come out
I've got loads of footage lying around
from me getting ready for it so I
thought I'll put that one out and then I
tell you what Tom dropped the many black
trailer and I was absolutely fuming
about it I was that have sat doing these
I wouldn't have bothered doing them if
I'd know men in black was out I love he
do really good really good trailer I
love a good boy trailer horrendous I
look like you did immortal engines
ending explained it's like oh man I mean
alright though is this slow week
sometimes Tom you know I mean you cry
games and in explains why you can't
smash brothers ultimate burden to videos
on that because Netflix blocked the
first one
I'm sorry edit it and put it back up but
you know Tom the channel there's loads
of stuff on
I've just had AB I know he's checked out
my my Aquaman breakdown video and he
said clickbait [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Wow so
getting lots of positive responses on
the videos and obviously subscribe to us
as well on iTunes and you get the
pockets there check out my shows as well
Bauer at resume and alphabet' aleca if
you enter Metallica I'm going through
their entire back catalogue song by song
I'm gonna be finished around June 2020
and we're doing one a week for the past
18 months so they'll probably release a
new album Tom they probably will they
literally probably well and I was they
have I'm a bit of a pariah in the scene
actually because I don't like the new
album at all and a lot of people get
annoyed about it but hard boy IDs are
very good people but well it's all good
it's all good
me and deaf will be back I'm sure
something soon probably before we do
Doomsday Clock 9 but um any any closing
thoughts how sick of it
8 is my favorite number Tom I was born
on the 8th of the 8th 1988 my first
house that I lived in what the number
was 8 the my grandmother's house is it's
number 8 this is the worst thing I've
come across with the number 8 in it in
my whole life Tom horrendous what was
what was issue a of watchman oh it was
it was the prison break one okay that's
it
Wow yeah so you went from one of the
best to one of the worst yeah yeah well
we scored in an 8 out of 10
okay it's done with the Hollis Mason
statue on the cover that in gratitude so
so good but yeah this has been Tom and
death watching The Watchmen it's good
night from me it's a good night from
Queen oh and yeah merry Christmas
everyone as well it's Christmas in a few
days Christmas in might this might come
out after Christmas oh well have a good
New Year's doctor man's experiences all
holidays at once so exactly it's always
five o'clock somewhere when you dr.
Manhattan but yeah cheers guys sure
you